so you came into the house what was the
first thing you noticed well the dog
been kicked in but stood back in place
if you look from the inside Steve Wilson
is one of a quarter of a million
burglary victims each year this panel
BSE kick straight out so many times have
you been burgled
I got done twice in two weeks twice in
two weeks twice in two weeks what did
the police do well I'm not no better off
now than what it was then describe what
it's like when you find out you've been
burgled it's probably one of the worst
fails in your life good it does
everything you work for is just any
personal stuff you know everything you
worked for is gone
little shows and James and they took the
air Clippers heard about your pair did
you feel safe not really I don't feel
safe now the purpose of getting you up
here guys is to put a little operation
together to try and get our number one
and most wanted because we've had some
more burglaries overnight detectives up
the road in Darlington are hunting a 22
year old man believed to be responsible
for a series of burglaries the
intelligence that we've got suggests
that he is back in Darlington and
obviously as a series confirmed on CCTV
we have an idea of the area that he's
frequents the most and is to put sort of
teams up in that area in the hope that
between Soloff I was where there's being
Satan something previously we've got the
resources in place so that we can nab
him when he shows himself so a good day
a good end to today it would be to
arrest us lad absolutely 100 percent
that is our number one focus for today
for both ORS CID and for
response colleagues this could turn out
to be a bit of cat-and-mouse for the
police they think this suspect is in one
of six locations so they're gonna go
house to house and they're hoping
they'll find him PC Chris Jones has a
look around the back of the property
can't see much into yours mate you got
moving the back of the dress he's in the
back of the dress he's gone back into
the address definitely we're in the
addressing they know the suspects in the
house they just can't find him
then they hear movements above their
heads
he's in the Attic I can see hid
underneath there fella come downstairs
the officers strike looking thick man
faints not mention when questioned
similar in court intensity maybe give
them an arrest on suspicion of burglary
okay Michael dodsworth had been serving
a prison sentence for a string of
burglaries but was released early only
to start Bergling again it doesn't
always end this way just 3% of
burglaries are solved nationally by
police that's the lowest level in a
decade in Durham it's better around 18%
burglary is a priority for us it is up
there and simply because of the impact
that it does have on and on victims
thirdly does have a devastating impact
on a lot of people and so they're so fun
do you like this individual is one of
our and you know priorities well they
won't care delete it they don't care
they just want whatever possessions they
can get all those it's worth nothing to
them it's worth a lot to me
Michael Todd's worth pleaded guilty to
two counts of burglary and is waiting to
be sentenced McMartin Sky News
Darlington
[Music]